if there's one thing we can all agree on
it's that everybody hates hipsters right
you know it's the common enemy that we
all have that will unite us that will
remove all race and gender boundaries
and we will say we are humanity like
Independence Day and we will fight
against the hipsters even the hipsters
themselves who apparently don't even
know that they are hipsters will also
hate hipsters everybody is against the
same thing and it's kind of its kind of
beautiful in a way so you can imagine
the horror that you would experience if
you started noticing some of these
hipster like tendencies appearing in
your life that's my friends if I can
still call you friends after this is
what I am suffering from right now I
think the biggest and most telling
example for me was when I bought those
glasses I mean just just look at that to
be wearing the glasses the actual
ray-ban Wayfarers that you put on
something to turn it into a hipster this
is that's how you turn Arielle into
hipster Ariel by putting these on and
yet I am NOT going to do anything about
it
that's like these were expensive glasses
and I think I look good in them I do
miss it this is when this War II started
for me was when I was seeing in like a
trendy warehouse type coffee bar looking
around me and thinking huh there's a
hipster there oh there's no one look at
his funny mustache oh this everyone's a
hipster here why am I here so my
interpretation of the the hipster like
personality constitutes a couple of
things first off you like things
ironically that I think I can
comfortably say is something that I
don't do I have the things that I like a
lot and I like maybe even to some people
too much but I don't care cuz I like
them that to me is a nerd but then
there's the whole you know you know that
thing that everybody likes now I don't
like it but when nobody liked it that's
when I was a big fan oh anti cool that's
the thing I think that we all Center on
as being like hipsters what rubbish
people but I have to be honest with
myself and think how I ever have I ever
being that person have I ever been in
this situation where I'm like oh I like
that thing before everybody else did
doesn't that make me cool and honestly I
have I feel like as much as I can try to
point out and justify the things about
me that that aren't hipster esque
and be like no hipsters are like this
and I don't do that sort of thing there
is a nugget in my heart that is enjoying
things ironically there is definitely a
sense of comfort that I get when I am in
a warehouse that's been converted to a
coffee shop surrounded by lots of trendy
looking people I feel at home in that of
their cozy they do a good job decorating
I think if there is a moral to be found
here I don't want to find it because the
moral is that I think is probably a Ziva
this will be more comfortable there's
either a little bit of hipster in all of
us or there is a little bit of hipster
in me specifically and I am a hipster
but I don't want to have to deal with
that and the consequences of being that
person I could at least be the first
person who will actually admit that they
are a bit of a hipster as opposed to all
of the other hipsters that don't want to
admit it
there we go that's how I can feel
superior right Charlie out you've just
had the almost imponderable joy of
watching Charlie is so cool like which
makes you like cool okie dokie last
week's video in case you missed it which
is likely because of the way that
YouTube works these days hahahaha and
also the trailer from a new short film
because you know I will continue to
promote this until until everyone on the
planet is seeing it because that's what
you do when you make a film thank you
very much for sticking around have a
nice day